voilà ce qu'il reste de l'hôpital des
soeurs du rosaire des locaux détruits
qui témoigne de la nuit sanglante
traversée par le personnel soignant et
par les patients lors de la double
explosion du 4 août dernier
si certains s'en sont sortis avec
quelques blessures grâce à
l'intervention des équipes de sauvetage
d'autres n'ont pas eu cette chance de
murs sont tombés sur une employée de
l'hôpital et elle a eu de nombreuses
fractures
moi même j'ai été blessé une autre soeur
a subi des fractures
j'ai remarqué que j'avais une blessure
mais en même temps j'entendais des cris
venant des étages où se trouvaient les
patients j'ai monté rapidement les
escaliers pour voir ce qui se passait
j'ai vu une infirmière qui était blessé
à l'oeil
elle avait un bébé dans ses bras n'est
une heure avant je lui ai dit cours vers
un autre endroit où il ya moins de
danger
plus tard j'ai appris qu'elle était
morte au 7e étage je suis très attristé
que les gens se soient précipités vers
nous et que nous n'ayons pas pu les
aider de nombreux hôpitaux comme celui
ci ont été touchés à beyrouth les
établissements médicaux épargnés par la
catastrophe ont eux toujours face à une
saturation et une pénurie de matériels
dus à l'arrivée massive de blessés lors
de la déflagration
plusieurs pays se sont précipité au
chevet du pays du cèdre pour envoyer de
l'aide médicale dans la capitale
libanaise un soutien qui a permis de
fournir des soins médicaux à de nombreux
blessés
c'est le cas de cet hôpital de campagne
russe qui continue de soigner des
malades grâce à une équipe de médecins
et un équipement permettant de
travailler en situation d'urgence
un de mes amis est tombé de sa moto à
cause de l'explosion de beyrouth jeu
l'amener ici
et dieu merci nous avons reçu un bon
accueil de la part des médecins russes
dans leur hôpital de campagne
c'est une tumeur dans la tête de ce côté
et la calcification des vertèbres
cervicales
voilà la situation dans laquelle je suis
ici il on lève les éclats de verre
nettoie et bandes les blessures il y un
traumatologue qui s'occupe des fractures
il remet les eaux en place alors que le
liban tant difficilement de soigner ses
blessés et pleure ses morts
le pays s'enfonce un peu plus dans la
crise sociale
comme si la crise économique
suffisait pas